and tonight he passes gary carter
the hall of famer
for games caught
2057. and there he is the left-hander
kim
we understand his family is here
from south korea to watch him pitch in
person
for the first time in the major leagues
1-1
on the ground to the shortstop that's
paul de young
for this cardinal staff here's a 2-2 to
solano
and more
weak contact that's a replay of the
first batter
6-3 ground out
that ball driven out into right and it's
going to be handled
by carlson
and a guy who has faced them a lot in
his career going back to his reds days
is anthony de sclafoni you talk about a
nice sign this year i mean he's been
great for the san francisco giant club
there's a ground ball nice pick over
there
by wilmer flores
for the out
this will be picked up by the shortstop
tyro estrada
he swings away and pops it into shallow
right it will be
solano to grab it
a breezy first for diesel funny
bottom two from st louis tyler o'neill
will lead it off for the cards
and then he powers one out into deep
right and it will go
tyler o'neill gives the cardinals the
early lead looks like he just kind of
flips this thing out there outer part of
the plate you see that
neil it's up in the zone and he just
drives that thing i mean he knows it
when he hits it
you know and that's opposite field
really a nice job right there mikey
stremski you see he's just going back
and then doing the
obligatory jog
and we're underweight mike here at the
top of the third inning it's one nothing
cardinals
2-1 is chopped on the ground to de-young
is that a busy start
diesel funny out into right
off the bat of slater and tyler o'neill
won the gold glove last year
giants go quietly one nothing cards
[Music]
anthony scalvani back to work here it's
the bottom of the fourth inning
tyler o'neal pops up down a first base
side foul ground caught by ruff
this one hard on a hop
solano has plenty of time to get him
two quick outs
this will be caught
the giants have the
tying run in scoring position
and a high drive
that
bader will catch
nice job to get behind that ball and not
give flores any ideas
and he went around
and
i think he decided yep
i'm out
he didn't run
now we return to busch stadium the
bottom of the fifth with the cardinals
coming to the plate leading the giants
one to none
there is a called strike three the two
seamer came back over the outside part
of the plate and diesel funny has
his third strikeout
bader tops one to third
and flores will get him he gonna do what
he did in colorado
but he can still be attacked by kim
but he grounds out
kwang young kim has been tremendous here
in the month of july
austin slater in the air to right back
on it carlson
and he makes a catch
[Applause]
yeah that really was a nice play i've
seen carlson make a few of these in the
last few weeks
here he's just running straight back
directly over his head sticks that glove
up
see running a pretty good speed there
and
wall closing in one and two on uski
this in the middle of the diamond should
be routine and it is for edmond
go time for solano
and the ball hit pretty well but again
it'll be caught fader
d
is retired seven in a row the last man
to reach on him was uh goldsmith and he
extended his batting streak to
12 games when he singles
a rope to center
and it's going to be at the wall for a
double
[Applause]
you see that the positioning of the
outfielders in a
huge gap center right
no chance of running that down duggar
played safely off the wall and
top of the order now goldschmidt who
extended his hit streak in the third
for 12 games with a single
[Applause]
ball out of the right
it's back there and it's gonna go
a two-run shot for goldschmidt and it's
three-nothing
goldie not messing around at all here
this pitch
not a bad pitch out over the plate low
and
he goes deep to right he knows he just
puts his head down you know in his last
three games he's had three home runs
here's right-hander ryan helsley in for
kim
you just can't do this this you just
can't
[Music]
just got out of the way of that one as
it is
flores will advance to second
round ball that'll get into left
flores will be held at third and a
little trouble
o'neal will be charged with an error and
the giants get on the board flores was
not going to try to score until o'neal
bobbled it
it's three to one
a liner into center for a base hit
that's left-hander genesis cabrera
and he got him
98 well located up and away
a broken bat one bouncer
and he gets out of it
zach latel a 6-4 right-hander now
working
served into left but it's going to hang
up for slater
line for a base hit
he's got his third tonight
on the ground to third
and a bobble they do get the out at
second but that's it
and i would say this
zeppo hit in the air to right deep but
playable
is uh the guy who made the little bobble
probably say yeah give me the error i
don't want my pitcher charged with an
earned run we go to the night
then here's all-star alex reyes he's 20
for 20 this year
he's 22 out of 22 and save
opportunities to start his career one
shy of the record
ground ball toward right and it gets
under the glove of edmond and the tying
run will come to the plate
missed low
two on nobody out
two on no outs two run game
the pitch to duggar
popped him up
shallow left
infield fly rule in effect as
the young makes the catch that is a
that's an enormous first out isn't it
for reyes
3-2
here it comes
he got him on a slider in the dirt
[Applause]
route number two
ground ball the young will throw to
first and the cardinals
take game two of this series alex reyes
ties the major league mark with his 23rd
successful save to start his career
cardinals got just enough offense
tonight maybe the answer is dominant
starting pitching kim was great tonight